well new numbers from the clark county
school district regarding the
pre-kindergarten to third grade
student survey eight news now reporter
kristen drummond is live in the newsroom
now with a breakdown of those results
kristen well denise the school district
revealed earlier this month that 56
percent of families prefer the hybrid
plan
and 43 percent chose distance education
now after a public information request
we now know more details about the data
results show
more than 68 thousand families with kids
up to third grade completed the survey
every section of town said they
preferred hybrid learning over distance
education
especially in the summerlin and
henderson areas by 62 to 38 percent
as you see highlighted here under
district a and e but a majority of
students will continue distance
education during hybrid learning
the district gave me a breakdown of the
cohort numbers roughly 21 000 are in
cohort a
that group will be in school on monday
and tuesday and at home the rest of the
week
more than 19 000 in cohort b that is the
grouping class on
thursday and friday and around 51 000
will
will be doing distance education in
cohort c
now superintendent jar explained why it
doesn't match the survey results
we sent out the survey if we need to
receive um an answer then we would
put them in um in the distance education
that's one and then parents had a choice
parents
have a choice to decide if they want
cohort a b
and if they decided that they want to
change their mind and go to distance
education that's up to the parent choice
those identifying as asian pacific
islander and limited english proficient
preferred distance education
while the other ethnic groups and
students receiving special education
services
requested hybrid learning including 67
percent who identify as caucasian
and about 63 percent who identify as
native american
the principal at gerheim elementary
school tells me his staff plans to be
flexible and ready just in case
more students want to come back once
fourth and fifth graders
return to the buildings on april 6.
reporting live in the newsroom kristen
drummond
8 news now